cómo
por favor
[Aplausos]
escándalo acción colectiva las
universidades de eeuu las más felices
demandadas por vicios en su sistema de
admisión escándalo la deuda
universitaria allí a los 38 mil millones
de dólares escándalo los egresados de la
carrera de derecho no tienen las
herramientas para enfrentar al mundo
real porque los negocios no se hacen en
latín y las máquinas leen más rápido el
código civil
y se acabó y se acabó el tiempo en el
que hay que trabajar para pagar una
carrera que estudiamos para poder
encontrar un trabajo se acabó la
burocracia y la despersonalización en
las entidades universitarias se acabó la
idea de que las mentoría son un capricho
de los millennials
porque se acabó esto el mundo el mundo
en los últimos años ha cambiado una
velocidad impresionante hace unos diez
años mis papás me dieron tres lecciones
tres lecciones que voy a la fecha no se
me olvidan uno que es
no hables con extraños
2 no te subas al coche de un extraño
3 la tarjeta de crédito se utiliza única
y exclusivamente para emergencias y hoy
hoy he aquí en el coche de un tal simón
así que le conté que estoy hasta el tope
de chamba y además le pagué con mi
tarjeta de crédito que está sobregirada
y las enseñanzas la madre quedaron
obsoletas quien dice quien dice que no
va a quedar obsoleto cuáles son los
pasos para hacer un poda o cómo calcular
deducciones autorizadas si quien dice
que no va a quedar obsoleto que una
carrera que en teoría dura cuatro años y
papas se paguen 14 no quien dice que no
va a quedar obsoleto que tengamos
instituciones de pisos de 20 30 pisos
vacías
con libros que no se abren
sí señores esto se acabó esto se acabó
porque las universidades creo yo no
quieren ser el nuevo blockbuster no las
universidades las universidades quieren
ser el nuevo de flix las universidades
quieren seguir propuestas como la de
milton friedman y propuestas como las de
la universidad de yale para crear nuevos
vehículos de inversión para crear nuevas
formas de financiar la educación para
crear nuevas formas de obtener
beneficios y cuáles cuáles son estas
formas milton friedman propuso unos
contratos que se llaman contratos de
capital humano qué carambas es un
contrato de capital humano si es un
acuerdo en virtud del cual un
inversionista va a financiar la carrera
de un estudiante a cambio de un
porcentaje de sus ingresos en el futuro
si yo te doy una lana para que estudie
soy para que estudies tu carrera para
que te mantengas y el día de mañana el
día de mañana me tocará una porción de
lo que llegue esto a ghana
ojo esto no es un préstamo si no tenemos
que entregar el capital si no si no una
porción de las ganancias en el futuro y
para que se hace es se hace para alinear
incentivos y vamos a lograr la
alineación de incentivos entre los
estudiantes entre las universidades y
entre los inversionistas que que están
buscando a fin de cuentas los
inversionistas nuevas maneras de cómo
utilizar su dinero y cómo generar mayor
ganancia vaya este esquema es el mismo
el mismo que utilizan los fondos de
capital privado en sillicon valley para
fondear a los nuevos uber los nuevos
netflix los nuevos facebook si este
proyecto es exactamente el mismo que
utilizan y que escriben en sus
pizarrones blancos con plumón verde
mientras toman café caro es exactamente
el mismo y tampoco es nuevo porque es
exactamente el mismo que utilizaban los
mecenas de la edad media para que
después les hicieran esculturas de
personas que eran evidentemente más
guapos de lo que eran en realidad
simplemente trasladar este mismo esquema
hacia una nueva forma de alinear los
incentivos vamos a trasladarle el riesgo
financiero el riesgo financiero papas si
de pagar una carrera si lo vamos a
trasladar a quien a un inversionista si
estudiante foráneo el riesgo financiero
que te gastas en tus latas de atún no
lo vamos a trasladar a un inversionista
que espero que tiene algo más que latas
de atún o que no te lo gastes en el de
anáhuac
entonces si le trasladamos el riesgo
financiero que vamos a lograr pues que
el estudiante en teoría se enfoque en la
academia se enfoque en su desarrollo se
enfoque en crear se enfoque en crecer en
ser mejor en ser mejor estudiante porque
ese su única chamba ahora que va a ser
que va a ser el inversionista el
inversionista lo que va a buscar es
relacionarse con el estudiante si el
inversionista es en relación con el
estudiante las posibilidades de éxito
son mucho mayores evidentemente si le
presenta gente si lo mentores si lo
lleva a trabajar si esto va a significar
que el día de mañana va a tener más
oportunidades tiene más oportunidades el
negocio va a ser mejor porque va a
obtener un beneficio mayor el día que
tenga derecho un porcentaje de su sueldo
de sus ganancias
si se levantan las cejas no empieza lo
raro oye mal esto suena muy parecido a
un tema de esclavitud esto suena muy
parecido al trabajador no abonado de
carolina del norte los que estudian
relaciones internacionales solamente
ellos entienden ese chiste
se parece mucho qué vamos a hacer cómo
vamos a hacer ok vamos vamos a discutir
los puntos técnicos vamos a discutir los
puntos lentos sí que se relacionan con
este con esta historia legalmente cómo
va a funcionar pues es un tema
contractual vamos a ponernos de acuerdo
para que los incentivos estén alineados
para que los incentivos estén
exactamente en el mismo canal
cómo es esto oye si tú supieras x monto
si no me tienes que pagar si tú vas
inventas el nuevo über de comida para
mascotas o la red social de perros lo
que quieras
y te vuelves millonario me pagas hasta
cierto monte 2 no tienes que tomar
decisiones que yo te imponga no si si tu
quieres mandar por el caño todo lo que
has hecho todo lo que has trabajado es
tu problema
y 3 vamos a establecer un programa de
trabajo y un cronograma de logros no
porque a fin de cuentas pues hay que
tener todas las caras de la moneda si en
las universidades establecen criterios
para mantener una beca que sabemos que
es más difícil de mantener que la
compostura cuando me tengo el mui muñoz
si no preguntale a quién sigue
si es difícil mantener una beca ahora
imagínense mantener bueno pues una
inversión de alguien que está
literalmente apostando en ti no tiene
que haber ciertas reglas no no quiere
decir que te tienen que obligar a ser
equis o ye manera pero si a lo mejor
seguir ciertas bailes tons mantener
cierto promedio participar en ciertos
programas ir a un interés y pena alguna
en alguna empresa en la que estés
recomendado de qué se trata vuelvo a lo
mismo de alinear incentivos
y esto éticamente nos permite nos
permite imitar un tema de esclavitud
moderna que nos permite evitar abusos
ahora normalmente cuando empiezan a
hablar de este tipo de temas la gente
luego luego se lanza vamos a hablar de
cómo lo vamos a solucionar con
tecnología hay una cosa a la vez si
entendimos cómo funciona si entendemos
cómo funciona podemos empezar a hablar
cuáles son los mecanismos para lograrlo
sí porque es muy fácil empezar a
utilizar palabras vacías como disrupción
transformación digital y blokes e
iniciación del match in learning de la
yautía al cuadrado y no me abuela
no es el punto entonces qué vamos a
hacer
podemos utilizar un esquema de
financiamiento colectivo en el que todos
nos juntamos y le apostamos al más listo
ok
podemos utilizar una compañía
institucional que ponga que ponga dinero
que ponga su nombre para desarrollar una
persona ok si podemos utilizar los
llamados activos virtuales ok y ahora es
donde entro en este punto de los activos
virtuales qué diablos es esto los
activos virtuales los llamaron así en
una nueva ley que se llama ley fintech
porque se escribe fintech aunque yo no
sé de dónde sacaron la dge porque es de
tecnología financiera y no hay ningún
hachís en tecnología pero nos encanta
inventar cosas
entonces en esta nueva ley dijeron que
los activos virtuales son monedas
digitales ok y las monedas digitales
están en una tecnología que se llama
blogging y que es bloque blogging ok es
una base de datos distribuida que todos
vamos a la que todos vamos a colaborar y
validar información imagínense que nos
sentamos todos aquí en este circuito
rojo ok y vamos a trasladar los valores
no yo le quiero comprar una mochila a mi
amiga de aquí adelante no y digo le voy
a trasladar 10 pesos a mariah ok y todos
van a agarrar uno de los folders que
tienen delante de ustedes lo van a abrir
y en una hoja en blanco van a escribir
maule paso 10 pesos amaría todos lo van
a hacer y después andrés lo hace y juan
y louis y empiezan a trasladar dinero y
empiezan a pagar si a comprarse cosas
todos juntos se nos va a llenar la hoja
en blanco no en el momento que se llena
la hoja en blanco las cerramos con un
folder sí y le ponemos un sellito que va
a ser único que nadie va a poder abrir
después lo volvemos a hacer con otra
hoja y otra hoja y otro ojo
si yo levantó la mano y dijo quiero
comprar otra vez la mochila no me van a
dejar porque porque ya la compré y
porque en otro folder ya estará
registrado eso eso es blocks y
validación de información validación de
transmisión de valor y eso es lo que
podríamos lograr imagínense que la misma
mesa estuvieran sentadas todos los
actores las universidades los
inversionistas los empleadores y los
estudiantes y que lográramos lográramos
que validar en información validar amos
que una empresa aún de algún buscador
dijera oye el cis taco x promedio oye el
sí participó en esto el inversionista
dijera oye él me promete que tiene tal
proyección financiera porque es muy
bueno en matemáticas de verdad lo es
si queremos encontrar estos vehículos de
inversión y queremos lograr estos
esquemas en los que las universidades
tengan más estudiantes mejor preparados
la única manera es generando confianza y
como generamos confianza compartiendo
los información unos con otros
si nos compartimos información unos con
otros vamos a poder saber a dónde vamos
y qué estamos logrando ok ahora mi juego
favorito en el casino se llama blackjack
y tú necesitas tener fichas y para poder
participar tienen que ser las fichas del
casino si tú quieres ir al bellagio con
unas fechas del casino de aquí afuera
pues se van a reír de ti porque esta
ficha te permite que te permite
participar en ese casino y te permite
apostar dinero esto significa dinero y
significa un derecho que logramos con
esto imagínense que pudiéramos generar
fichas si para poder participar en este
esquema que una grande empresa
telefónica o una gran empresa de
internet comprara fichas a las
universidades para encontrar a sus
mejores alumnos y estas fichas
representarán el conocimiento
tiempo o el futuro de cada uno de estos
alumnos que ya han sido aprobados por
las universidades si vamos a jugar
blackjack pero vamos a jugar blackjack
con las reglas correctas si nosotros
logramos generar monedas y generar valor
de las habilidades del conocimiento y
del tiempo vamos a poder vender hacia
afuera estudiantes mejor preparados
estudiantes cuyas monedas se pelean
todas las universidades estudiantes
cuyas monedas se pelean todas las
compañías no olvidemos la dimensión de
la persona a ojo y no olvidemos no
olvidemos que a fin de cuentas estamos
hablando del tiempo de alguien
como le vamos a hacer ahí es donde están
las reglas por eso tenemos que
participar todos por eso tenemos que
estar involucrados universidades
inversionistas empleadores y también
estudiantes si lo logramos vamos a poder
lograr que andrés ayala andrés coin y
mariah la maria coin y las vendamos
porque hoy no podemos vender una hora
nuestra podemos vender el producto del
trabajo que hacemos en una hora pero
nunca podemos tener una hora todos
tenemos 24 horas y 7 días a la semana
hay unos que dormimos más otros menos y
por eso tenemos estas ojeras
pero si logramos si logramos darle valor
al tiempo si logramos darle valor al
tipo que es algo que todos tenemos y que
tenemos estamos en la misma cancha
pareja vamos a encontrar mayores
oportunidades de inversión y mayores
oportunidades de desarrollarnos
personalmente que a fin de cuentas es lo
que queremos lograr a nosotros no nos
interesa no nos interesa construir más
edificios nos interesa hacer la
diferencia y que nos den nos den las
herramientas para hacer la diferencia y
una tecnología como blogging nos permite
hacerlo aprovechemos la aprovechemos la
con la dimensión ética y legal que
corresponda pero hagámoslo
exijamos exijamos estas medidas exijamos
que se involucren compañías con las
universidades exijamos que los
inversionistas puedan pensar en el
futuro de los jóvenes todos los días nos
dicen no sólo el futuro de mexico pero
quien ha puesto un peso en la línea por
el llamado futuro de mexico quien lo he
hecho y si de esta manera lo hacemos
vaya que lo vamos a lograr vaya que
vamos a lograr una sociedad que sea más
justa
más incluyente y que lógicamente
funcione mejor porque tenemos los
incentivos alineados y ahora sí ahora sí
hagamos un escándalo
hagamos un escándalo porque logremos
llevar la educación a todos los rincones
de mexico hagamos un escándalo porque
logremos transformar el tiempo en
nuestro activo más valioso y hagamos un
escándalo porque potencializar hemos
nuestros talentos con los talentos de
los demás muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]